[Music]
from mcdonald's mcplant burger to
chipotle's plant-based teresio
meatless options are did i say that it's
a chorizo i think tourism
all of a sudden i saw patty cracking up
options are going mainstream the food
revelation in restaurants across the
country has its roots in america's
heartland and it's powered by peas nancy
chen reports on what's happening from
table to farm
near times square one of the best joints
for a burger with all the fixins
isn't serving any meat
april tam smith is the co-founder of p.s
kitchen the vegan restaurant was one of
the first in new york city to serve the
brand beyond meat back in 2017. i
remember when we first opened the
questions were usually around what's in
this wow it's really good what am i
eating fast forward to today as meat
alternative products are creating new
appetites for all the people who are
coming in wanting to try this burger are
they vegetarian or are they meat eaters
i would say mostly meat eaters i think
about 80 percent of our customers are
just regular people people were just
craving the burgers changing the
nation's taste buds isn't easy while
recent survey found nearly 9 in 10
americans eat meat as part of their diet
25 percent say they're at least willing
to try plant-based burger alternatives
that includes this oklahoma girl so this
is the beyond meat burger and there's
absolutely no meat in this no not at all
it's made with pea protein all right
this is really good
it just tastes like a regular burger
as for where much of it comes from near
the south dakota border in dawson
minnesota are the seeds of a food
revolution brother and sister tyler
lorenzen and nicole atchison had the
largest pea protein plant in north
america what exactly is pea protein pea
protein is protein that comes from peas
and not green peas actually yellow field
peas there's actually 20 percent protein
in peas
which is quite a bit for most vegetables
a chance to change what we eat and how
we farm nicole i was surprised to learn
i mean even on the drive in here i'm
passing fields of crops that those crops
aren't necessarily going to people and
for the most part they're actually going
to livestock
yeah and that's i think surprising for a
lot of people because as we drive around
we think oh look at all this food that
we're making
pearis works with a network of more than
400 farmers to source their pea plants
peas are actually one of the most soil
nurturing plants you can grow which is
great for healthy crop rotations what
does this mean for farmers in the united
states these days we've worked over the
last 20 years to adapt varieties that
can grow right in the heartland peas
aren't typically grown in canada and so
we've really adapted them to new
climates which gives farmers more
revenue opportunities one of the biggest
customers for their pea varieties is
beyond meat found not only in ps kitchen
but now mcdonald's taco bell and panda
express it seems like the industry of
plant-based protein has really gone
through a revolution these past few
years yeah i think the biggest change
has been the products on the market
really mimicking their counterparts that
are coming from animal proteins with
flavor and looks pea protein is proving
to be more than just a food trend the
meat eaters that are coming in and
trying these plant-based burgers what
are they seeking i think often it's
it really is just genuinely delicious
you don't really feel like you're
missing out on something but the same
time a lot of us are more aware of the
environmental impact now so it's really
a win-win for the consumer for the
environment and for our bodies for cbs
mornings i'm nizi-chen in dawson
minnesota
thank you nancy chen there's another
option for you to try
i like yes
we'll see you tomorrow